ciao ragazzi ben tornato nella puntata
di cucina buttata blog mas edition come
vedete abbiamo messo tutto quanto qua ci
sta un orrendo bambo rottino morto cioè
un albero di natale c'è un cappello di
natale di tutto quanto a rendervi felici
e siccome leggiamo i vostri commenti e
ci teniamo tantissimo quello che ci dite
avete detto che vi mancava un pochino un
senso di cucina perché questa roba è
troppo moderna non vedi ace e perché che
belli che so non lo so quelle cose tipo
bruciare le streghe e tutte quelle altre
robe medievali che ci piacciono tanto
perché il progresso ci fa schifo il
vaccino fa male a tutti quanti noi siamo
contrari al 5 gb assolutamente fermato
fermato fermato fermato abbiamo deciso
di mettervi il forno che ci avete
chiesto gli utensili lavandino eravate
disperati per il lavandino eccoli qua
oggi però all'interno di cucina buttata
non sarò da solo come ci sarà una
professionista del film sto parlando di
mia cugina giulia ciao giulia come
staiano felicità dice tu sei la maestra
la professionista indiscussa degli omini
pan di zenzero si sentisse l'unica cosa
mi pare l'unica che ha fatto in famiglia
li ha portati al giorno darebbero ha
detto che buoni e belli quindi oggi li
faremo facciamoli pronta prontissima dai
è ok detto ciò sigla
[Musica]
ingredienti per fare gli omini di pan di
zenzero avremo bisogno di
350 g di farina 160 grammi di zucchero
di canna 110 grammi di burro freddo di
frigo un nuovo 50 grammi di miele 5
grammi di cannella in polvere 5 grammi
di zenzero in polvere è un pizzico di
sale chiodi di garofano non si moscata e
mi carbonato allora giulia diciamo tutto
è presente tutte queste belle e spezie
cucchiaini butta tutto dentro al 15 a
causa dei cretini a veri allora abbiamo
lo zenzero da camminare ma veniamo alla
cannella è normale che abbia una sua
strana consistenza a chi serve quel
bicarbonato serve a farlo gonfiare così
diventano belli e
famosi gonfiare il noce moscata un bel
pizzico di chiodi di garofano tutti di
cumulo un pizzico di cui uno mi dice
tutto generoso ma sa che interesse viste
le ultime puntate lui col sale da un
hummer vuole un po di sale
adesso tagliamo il book cioè tagli il
burro a pezzetti vi freddo giusto ed ho
freddo dei chiostri ed è perché sennò
alterare la struttura della frolla
comunque posso dire una cosa io non
gradisco per niente la sua presenza
ma voi sapete la mia macchina squadra
fobia delle bambole noli terrorizzati
qualcosa appena l'ho visto ho detto non
andrò mai più a studio da loro trovarli
ho un'idea che possiamo che non mette su
un appello che inquadrano i bisogni car
cm che rendere man e se volete ma poi se
ne sta pregando
diventato suo personaggio non me lo fate
vedere se devo a questo malato massaggia
il burro con la farina beatrice deve
diventa parmigiano alla fine come
consistenza guardato e parmigiano giu
senti dei tocchi grandi ci dai libri di
fisica ma almeno 900 va bene così non è
stato si chiama cucina buttata vi diamo
dei quali già partito
6 accendendo i fornelli allora secondo
me era un appello poi andiamo bene vado
possono così fare aggiungono zucchero ma
ha poi mi piace con noi no amici di
lacco ma che tipo lo dovresti mangiare
cucchiai etti
io lo trovo in mondo sono contento io
trovo il miele un
un alimento il mondo cosa tu mangia il
formaggio senza miele quello bello stata
data risposto che diciamo che il
formaggio medici panfocaccia sarà in
ottavi migliorando negli ultimi anni
in fondo alla catena alimentare
ma ragazzi
sapete quello che dite
secondo me non l'hanno mai saputo
mangiare come si deve
[Musica]
alle risate
deformazione tu mi sento a posto eh sì
per forza ora da sei li metta a posto
anche la persona dalla sinistra di
ragazzi come suono
stessi parlando del suono che faceva la
pasta ho detto che c'erano delle specie
di antenne che riescono a sentire agli
impasti mi sussurra dopo l'uomo che
sussurrava ai cavalli la donna che
sussista dell'imposta è fatto
[Musica]
poi vai vai
tanto tu mi capisci
ok perfetto dargli una forma tondina
carina panetto pellicola figo ma perché
non bisogna che il capo troppo giusto
lavorare in fretta poi certo devi se non
vieni
anche tu non viene anche gli aussie che
è il dolce punto non te lo facciamo
riposare in frigo ma il minimo
sindacabile direi che è una mezz'oretta
sarebbe meglio farlo il giorno prima ma
chi sono io per dirvi i vostri vecchi
come gestirli
meno sindacabile mezz'ora ma la cosa
migliore è un giorno prima è la e noi lo
faremo riposare mezz'ora per colpa è
perfetto ecco qui il nostro rimpasto mai
lo stia appoggiato andiamo ad aprirlo
stendiamo di utenti qui si possono
vedere con bertorello ormai vari si farà
mai a il trucco per tendere la bell
omogenea e ogni tanto gira cioè continui
a tenere ma giri sotto sia dall'olio
personale di luglio
faccio una cosa mi sembra abbastanza
prestante questo impasto
le vere professionisti
che tutti pensano che nelle pasticcerie
si suoni l'armonica mentre cantano gli
unicorni velata siamo dei fatti
si finisce di stendere valori a mezzo
centimetro
così quando senti che si attacca un po
magari lo speriamo della ratta
trasferta sulla carta non mi sento
sicuro
non portare qui è il mio credo in te tu
non sai che si va in cucina e non ci
vanno più in pasticceria
questa è la prima di compleanno
sticazzi ragazzi come un laico per uno
stick a xvi gli auguri
da ambe le chiamiamo
i commenti fate auguri dei perdenti
auguri graziana tu guarda un altro ci
sei quasi
troppe volte mi hanno detto ci sei quasi
niente alla fine è arrivato il
vaccino io che vive nella famiglia sono
io l'ho focaccina lo sto creando
ci viene voglia di dirlo all'infinito
vuoi dirlo anche tu giammarco
l'uomo focaccina dai perfetto andiamo
non bel dato concreto giusto mai da ogni
ea questo punto quando giuliano 160
gradi forno statico per 20 25 minuti a
guardare non solo nei vostri corpi
e le fate voi fate voi ok andiamo
ops non proprio qui credo
quando
addio tanti consensi
addio
ragazze ma possiamo parlare della
dolcezza di questi piccoli sensi sono
stupendi ragazzi li abbiamo fatti e
riposare per tv una menzione detta in
modo da essere più bollenti anche un
pochino seccarsi quindi giu cosa devo
fare adesso cosa devi fare perché io me
ne vado ma come gli impegni edifici è
mai facile alta fantasia e tanta
creatività e margine bocca al lupo
giulia cifra lasciando numero di marche
adesso vengono le parole ma che succede
non lo so è un giro quindi la cura
slovenia che daranno dei mostri tre cose
curiose zip un mostro
[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora ragazzi la cosa fondamentale per
decorare gli uomini e tanta fantasia un
top family come me pare e se li farete
vi prego attacca temi su instagram come
sempre iscriviti che questo canale
metteteci un bel pollice in su che
fateci sapere quali sotto quali sono
altre ricette natalizie che potremmo
magari utilizzare nelle prossime puntate
di cucina buttate inizio del rock ma
detto ciò passiamo all'assaggio allora
prendo noi
dunque sono bellissimi sono bellissimi
da vedere questi sono carini anche se
gli fai un buchetto e poi apprendi
all'albero in cima a questo che l'ho
ammazzato invece non è andata così non è
andata bene vado
con buonissimi io adoro il panni gente
proprio perfetto perfetto auguriamo
con lavate fiera della sua battuta ci
sei rimasto malissimo marino
assaggiate arriva una cosa io non sono
fan dello zenzero ma questa mi ricorda
tutto tu io non sono falle dei dolci in
generale come tu sai che bello che bello
non vedo l'ora di far bene a saggiare
la morte e mangiando il nuovo morello
oppure morto almeno me magna un cadavere
e duro morte poco vado
ora buona la concessione sono un mero
spettacolo iniziale come
cioè all'insù avuto la sensazione di
dover avere le fasi di uno squalo bianco
ossia però con la bella man ci vivrei
carinissimo una decorazione e dolcissima
ma non lo finisco cioè non è un riscatto
e di chi non è vero che io finisco che
vorrebbero un botto
ricordi ricordi una ricetta dove
graziano ha detto sì che buona no non è
vero altro che bush ha detto che cos'è
ma che volere un programma settata
un'altra parte quello che vuoi chiamare
biglietti perché dipende dei bifolchi
nel kentucky quelli pieni di formaggio
erano bonino
per azione altro ci vediamo martedì con
una nuova puntata del blog nas quota a
milano ciao
[Applauso]
[Musica]